à 20 ans à l'épicerie on essayait
souvent de comprendre pourquoi on avait
si peu accès à nos produits de la mer ya
bien sûr comme réponse possible que
c'est une question de distribution de
grandes distances à parcourir de coûts
élevés et de demandes timide de la part
des consommateurs mais on nous dit que
les choses pourraient changer si on s'en
donner la peine
si vous êtes dans le paradis de l'ours
un verre dans l'estuaire
nos plongeurs sont à l'eau en ce moment
on devrait sortir avec environ 500 lits
dans les minutes qui suivent d'ailleurs
pendant ma lança environ un million de
livres 10 pêche un peu plus la première
nation ou la stocker ou est quoi cette
époque on récolte environ un quart de sa
saison si l'on se retrouve à las vegas à
manhattan dans les plus beaux casinos
les plus grands croisière est
intéressant votre autonomie vous avez
bien compris aucun humour simple de
cette pêche ne restera au québec un
discours qu'on entend depuis des années
mais aujourd'hui les pêcheurs et
transformateurs en ont assez l'épicerie
est à les entendre ce qu'ils proposent
pour changer la donne
ce extraordinaire savons sans qu'on
connaisse c'est celle de nous encore un
18 24 mois puis on va être capable de
s'occuper du marché domestique avec soin
qui pourquoi ça peut être fait avant
bonne question
c'est ce qu'elle nous dit que c'est
compliqué et les attribuer au québec le
québec maritime est un vaste territoire
c'est une pêcherie de volumes qu'on doit
ensuite fractionné en petites commandes
d'un peu partout sur le territoire c'est
ce qu'on sait ce qui est quand même très
compliqué alors que une exportation
massive un seul client une seule facture
un seul camion un seul os est très
facile point de vue administratif par
contre ça augmente la dépendance un seul
acheteur ce serait quand même
intéressant d'avoir plusieurs acheteurs
québécois qui se mêlerait à la partie
ben voilà ça serait même nécessaire de
diversifier nos marchés ouvrir nos
opportunités puis d'être moins dépendant
d'un seul client
on a des projets en cours pour des
études de préfaisabilité mena
possiblement à l'établissement d'une
usine de transformation de produits
marins de l'oursin inverse
spécifiquement cette volonté de
diversifier les marchés au profit du
québec résonne de plus en plus mais
garder nos richesses et vouloir les
transformer chez nous est un long chemin
parsemé d'obstacles
c'est compliqué pour commencer sa de
longue haleine ce sont des procédés
administratifs qui sont l'un et
est lourd
le cac ouvre maintenant on s'en va à
rimouski rencontré emmanuel et guillaume
c'est un pêcheur et un océanographe qui
ont décidé d'unir leurs forces pour
ouvrir une nouvelle usine de
transformation des produits de la mer
[Musique]
le principe de chasse marée c'est
vraiment que notre source est pêché en
face on sait qu'il a pêché comment a été
pêché rang dans cette bâtisse répète
maintenions vivier ou transformer
directement puis ensuite est mis en
conserve
avec un mot je sais que c'est pas le
produit exactement fini sur ceux des
tests de bourgaud à l'huile de cameline
et au carvi savage ça donne une
bourgault qui a une tendreté vous allez
voir au final
on est ailleurs
ce qui semblait être une superbe idée
est devenu presque un cauchemar on peut
qualifier le parcours administratif de
chasse marée de long chemin de croix
leur demande de permis pour transformer
le bourgault qu'ils pêchent eux-mêmes a
été refusé une fois par le mapaq on
craignait une compétition déloyale avec
d'autres usines un manque de main
d'oeuvre la surpêche de certaines
espèces pourtant une compétence qui
relève du fédéral et non d'une attaque
je sais pas combien de projets ont été
abandonnés en cours de route parce que
justement ils se sont pas rendus sur
toutes ces étapes si mais si on avait
pris la première lettre de refus on
aurait arrêté cela il ya un an et demi
on est une petite unité de
transformation on veut faire quelque
chose d'un peu différent puis on dirait
que toute la législation actuelle est
basée sur un modèle des volumes l'a
finalement d'exploitation de gros
volumes fait que vous vouliez partir une
l'usiné qui fait des millions de livres
pour des espèces de crabes you may ou
que vous vouliez faire une petite
conserverie vous êtes dans le même quart
quand administratif l'a finalement alors
je vais avoir les reins solides faut
avoir de la volonté faut avoir une
certaine résilience nous on voulait
aller dans ce créneau là de la
valorisation de la démocratisation
d'espèces un petit peu moins connus et
qui pourtant sont toutes exporté
l'extérieur parce qu'elles ont cette
valeur puis cet intérêt la cedh
excellent produit on a des eaux d'une
immense qualité tout le monde nous envie
pour ça mais on prend nos produits on
les envoie extérieur on a eu des avants
des tapes dans le dos à droite à gauche
on a une certaine reconnaissance avant
même d'avoir finalement mis en marché
nos produits mais au niveau du mapaq
c'était plus compliqué ce que
chasse-marée demandé c'était à
transformer de 0,1 pour cent à peu près
des volumes débarqué au québec donc
c'est une goutte d'eau dans l'océan
pourquoi une temps de résistance
derrière le dossier
selon l'institut de recherche en
économie contemporaine en 2018 90% des
produits de la mer consommés au québec
étaient importées alors qu'on exporte de
près de 80% de nos ressources
principalement ou trois produits par le
crabe des neiges le homard et la
crevette ce qu'on pense qu'il ya
derrière ce qu'on veut pas ouvrir la
porte un autre modèle une autre manière
de faire on veut pas créer un précédent
pour ensuite ouvrir les vannes est en
fait rompre le statu quo aujourd'hui
qu'à un nouveau joueur arrive quand des
nouvelles idées arrivent il faut appeler
brasser les choses pour que chacun
puisse faire sa place sandra gauthier
directrice d'exploramer a initié le
premier salon fourchette bleue pour
réunir des joueurs qui veulent faire les
choses autrement il ya des pêcheurs qui
veulent de plus en plus vendre en direct
c'est un phénomène que je vois grandir
de plus en plus c'est une tendance qui
je pense va s'accroître si ça change
[Musique]
on a vu avec les guides de chasse marée
comment c'était compliqué de faire les
choses autrement l'on s'envoie dans la
baie des chaleurs à la pêche au homard
avec ghislain collet qui est celle de
démarrer une usine de transformation de
crabe commun et on va voir si connaît
les mêmes embûches
le creps comme un différent du crabe des
neiges est une espèce ni connu et peu
exploité ici l'objectif de ce pêcheur
restaurateurs le rendre accessible aux
québécois pour l'instant le frais ou
leur anti et plusieurs en distribuer à
écouler une grosse demande pour la chair
mais pauvre la chair pour vendre à des
industriels au blason des restaurateurs
ça prend une usine 130 promis de
transformation
avoir initié un permis de transformation
très très très très très très très
difficiles et j'avais bac à l'université
puis je suis pas capable pour ça
travaille d'abord un sous sol c'est trop
compliqué je crois qu'elle formulaire
effet en conséquence de nos programmes
en qui peuvent se qualifier mais c'est
un processus qui est en branle il faut
présenter premièrement paquet paperasse
assez volumineuse pièce c'est compliqué
pièces et détaillé pour passer un comité
consultatif qui fait des industriels et
demande
du québec et politiques et d'une attaque
il étudie la demande il faut pour
nuire un autre mais pourquoi les
industriels ont leur mot à dire pourquoi
les compétiteurs décide du permis que
vous fait avoir ou pas d'après moi c'est
dévié lois protectionnistes deviez
années que oui c'était pour protéger les
industries les emplois ici dans la
région on essaye d'un peu de prendre en
charge notre produit puis de l'offrir au
moins au québec en premier pourquoi vous
voulez absolument envoyer ça au québec
nous on le veut mais vous vous en dites
quoi votre intérêt mais au prix
meilleures conditions présentes mange
pas je sais même pas encore le prix de
mon produit ces produits là à l'heure
actuelle c'est pas le québec qui
détermine les prises c'est les états
unis qui détermine le prix que le québec
va acheter ses propres produits d'abord
pour commencer tant en termes
d'autonomie alimentaire ça ne peut pas
être un pays voit les nommer les états
unis qui décident de combien les
québécois vont payer leurs homards aulas
on sait demander aussi si le fait
d'avoir un accès direct ces produits de
la mer les rendrait plus abordable plus
accessible abordable je l'espère mais
pour l'instant ça coûte très cher
comprendre les industriels qui vendent
en grosse quantité c'est plus facile
pour les autres aussi la voie que je
prends c'est pas la plus facile c'est
pas la moins coûteuse mais si on est
plusieurs pêcheurs on va travailler
ensemble pour essayer d'offrir des
produits aux prix la valeur qui vont
vous
[Musique]